قدم الجبن واحصل على القرض الذي ترغب فيه
من البنك من دون اي ضمانات هذه ليست مزحه
انه عرض يقدمه بنك ايطالي للمزارعين حتى
يتحصلوا على قروض تصل الى الاف الدولارات
والضمان الوحيد هو الجبن لكن ليس اي نوع
فيجب ان يكون
برمجيان رجيانو الذي يوصف بملك الاجبان
فما هو سر هذا الجبن وما الذي سيستفيد منه
البنك
يعامل هذا النوع من الاجبان كثروه النفيسه
فيخزنه في مستودعات شديده الحراسه بها
كاميرات مراقبه ودوريه امنيه لحمايته من
عمليات السطو المسلحه والسرقه اقراص الجبن
الصلبه هذه منسوعه الدسم وثقيله في
الميزان فالقرص الواحد منها قد يصل وزنه
الى 35 كلغ بسعر 2500 دولار وما يجعلها
باهظه الثمن هو ندر فهذا النوع من الجبن
الذي تم انتاجه منذ الف عام بايطاليا لن
يتمكن احد من نسخه لانه ببساطه يصنع من
حليب سلاله خاصه من الابقار البيضاء
المهدده بالانقراض ولم يتبقى منها سوى اقل
من 500 بقره في ايطاليا وصناعه قرص واحد
فقط من الجبن تحتاج ما يعادل الى 550 لترا
من الحليب السبب الاخر في كون سعره مرتفعا
للغايه هو انه يحتاج لفتره طويله في
التخزين قبل ان يصبح جاهزا للبيع وقد تصل
الى ثلاثه اعوام كحد اقسى وكلما طالت
المده زاد صاروا قرص الشعب